let's just begin uh with the latest on
the ground and what's happening in the
Russian offensive yes I mean the donbass
doesn't look as if it's changed very
much the battlefield's here but there's
quite a lot going on as we're under the
surface we all talk about back motor
which is in its 10th almost 11th month
now of Agony
um and we are now in the end game a
month ago we thought we were in the end
game uh but in fact the the ukrainians
went back into back mutton effect they
decided to try to make it last a bit
longer because they're playing for time
but what's actually happening what's
more interesting in a way is that the
Russians are moving some of the best
forces around criminal which though
which is really important to them and
they're moving them down towards volada
and uh avdivka which are a a bigger
issue now vuladar in particular is
strategically important to them uh
avdivka is a bit like back mode they're
actually
demolishing the place and they're going
to take control of the rubble eventually
but the reason I think the Russians are
fighting so hard is avaduka and they're
moving some of the better troops down
there is they're trying to draw
ukrainians away from vulador which is
what they really want and so the the
though the battle is concentrated on
back mode in terms of the world's media
what's really happening is going on
atifa and vuladar down in the South and
ultimately the ukrainians are trying to
hold as much territory as possible to
play for time until they're offensive
can get going which will be when the
weather turns and when the ground is
hard enough for the armor that they've
accumulated over this period of the
winter
uh now on to the issue of landmines
Michael on one of my trips to Ukraine
last year I was taken to an area that
was completely contaminated with
landmines after Russian troops left and
it was painstaking trying to clear those
areas that represent such a threat to
civilians what's the latest on that
situation with trying to demine those
areas yes I mean the Ukrainian
government have said in the last 24
hours I can't give the whole khaki of
oblast the area in yellow there which
the Ukraine is liberated uh in the
Autumn that whole area is peppered with
Russian landmines these anti-personnel
land mines and the point is when a force
is retreating the way the Russians did
they leave mines in the way to slow down
the the troops that are chasing them in
effect that are pursuing them and the
the mainland mine in uh khaki which is
causing all the trouble is the butterfly
landmine it's 90 personal land mine it's
known as the butterfly the the Russians
developed it in the 1980s it's very
small as you can see that it's about as
big as your hand it carries about a four
gram charge very small charge which is
liquid explosive in the wings of the
thing and you if you pick it up it'll go
off in your hand it needs it needs a
tiny amount of pressure to set it off
it's not planted by anybody it's fired
from an artillery shell or it's dropped
by helicopters and aircraft so they
scatter thousands of them in one go and
they sit on the ground and they
camouflaged in grass and they just look
they're just there and they cause
immense harm not much to the military
the military can just go through these
things in their armored vehicles and if
the military needs to clear a field they
clear 20 of it and that takes them
through but civilians you can't go into
a field even if it's 90 clear because if
there's only 10 mines left out of 100
you still wouldn't go into the field so
these things have the effect of
preventing any agriculture going on
quite apart from anything else
and it's a big problem in the world
there are estimated to be about 110
million mines in the world still laid
still live
um every year about 5 000 people are
killed or injured by them somewhere in
the world about half of those people are
children and children are really at risk
of these sorts of things because they're
everywhere and very quickly you can't
really see them and there are great uh
organizations like the Halo trust who
lift these things and they're lifting
about a hundred thousand a year but
every year about two million mines are
sown somewhere in the world so it's a
huge problem and the Russians aren't
helping and just briefly Before I Let
You Go Michael the latest on these
classified documents that release were
released last week are highly sensitive
documents the US is really stepping up
its efforts to try and find a source of
this league what's the latest on that
and how how could it potentially impact
conflict yeah well good luck in finding
the source I mean it almost certainly
was somebody or maybe a couple of people
who were downloading documents
photographing them and then putting them
onto this Gaming website the uh the
Discord website where there was sitting
there for days before anybody noticed
that they were important so it has the
look of a sort of an informed amateur
about it I don't think it was uh we were
talking some computer nerds we're
talking about a nerd you know work but
working inside the system and the point
is that the reason that the Americans
are vulnerable to this sort of thing is
that their secret and top secret
material is shared among so many people
thousands of people have access to this
stuff so that's how the Snowden
revelations in 2015 2016 did so much
damage because it comes out uh in with
people I mean he was only a contractor
he didn't even work for the Pentagon
officially he was just a contractor but
he had access to all this stuff well and
so it caused into question the security
of absolutely and it's very embarrassing
for the Americans it doesn't make a lot
of difference to what's going on in
Ukraine to be honest but it's
embarrassing for them in terms of their
relation with Egypt with Iran over Korea
and with some of the European allies
because some of the stuff that's come
out on those issues is genuinely
something that was not known before
what's come out on Ukraine is only
really a confirmation of what we knew
already